greetings from podcast Ville it's
Wednesday the 6th the [ __ ]
November the rent is long overdue anyway
the church is brought to you by athletic
greens you like Joey what's athletic
greens it's an excellent awesome
supplement that gives you big dick swing
and energy right there in the mornings
listen if you're not starting your day
off with a blast of vitamins you already
lost the battle go back to bed
[ __ ] listen if you want to feel
tip-top Magoo let athletic greens do the
dirty work they got you covered by five
critical areas health energy immunity
gut health which is important and
hormonal support who else takes care you
like that nobody that's why I'm telling
you right now do me a favor go right
over that letter Q means calm and take a
look at what they have to offer this
website's tremendous I mean they might
want it they might have something I'm
not mentioning here but what I can
mention t is this stuff is tremendous I
drink one of these in the morning and
I'm ready to strangle a [ __ ] you
understand me to get what I'm getting
Yeti two dozen apples who's got time to
eat two dozen apples you'll be [ __ ]
blood for two weeks you understand me
listen athletic greens members the
church family get a special offer you
get twenty free travel packs value at
$79 with your first purchase all right
jump over to athletic greens comm and
get your travel packs today you're not
gonna be sorry that's last lennick
greens.com slash church athletic greens
tremendous also the holiday season's
coming that means a lot of sitting a lot
of [ __ ] around and mingling and you
want to meet new people
listen I've introduced you to manscape
how to keep your nutsack trimmed and all
that but you can trim your nutsack and
wash your dick all you want if you
[ __ ] smells like [ __ ] Saudi Arabia
after the bombing then Toshi is for you
you're like Joey what's tushy it's a
portable but Dan that you strap on
yourself and ten minutes and that's it
tushy sprays water straight directly
into ass and removes the old [ __ ] but
you're gonna juice or whatever else we
got sitting back there and that
[ __ ] bacteria that leads to nasty
things like hemorrhoids yeast infection
UTI itchy [ __ ] or skid marks but
days a common in the rest of the world
only here in America do we have to cut a
tree to wipe your ass no more
go to hell old Toshi calm right now and
take a look at the selections and colors
they got to match your toilet bowl let
me tell you something this is the way to
go wet wipes are worse than toilet paper
go back to using straws wet wipes and
toilet paper a killing the [ __ ]
environment they cause anal fissures
whatever the [ __ ] that is and you don't
want no anal fissure ring do you
nobody wants an anal fissure ewwww
unless your name is Chad and you want to
jump up and down on a Tuesday in Santa
Monica Boulevard
but besides that go to hello Trisha calm
right now and press in code Church and
get 10% of your let me tell you
something you're sitting there thinking
what am I getting a grandpa and grandma
for Christmas what am I gonna get my
parents for christmas technically your
mother's ass does it look like it needs
some water and that [ __ ] go -
hello - she calm right now press in
church and get 10% off your order do me
a favor Lily take this [ __ ]
mule what's happening your bad
[ __ ] Uncle Joe here with my
main number one [ __ ] Cuban the man of
the hour Rudy Sarzo mano get myself we
were talking about let me tell you
something III I met a guy here Davis
Jewish nicest Jewish guy you could ever
meet
nicer than then leave oh my older and
the conversation was great until he said
you know I don't know if he knows what
my wife is african-american I'm like you
dirty Jew bastard yeah I knew it I knew
it you love that dark mean [ __ ]
just not on Hanukkah so it was funny out
you know some people like certain women
you know I love being Cuban I love Cuban
people I'm very proud of my heritage one
thing I did not like since they want you
ready was those [ __ ] sweet 16
Becky's nine yet oh yeah oh yeah I went
to one oh yeah that was it here I mean
in Cuba or no I want the Union City what
one that tuxedo with 18 guys and tuxedo
chicks and dresses yeah and that
grandmother's there and you got a dance
six inches apart listen I'm going to
touch some titties and grab some [ __ ]
so you understand they can grab some
asses I don't want anything grandma's
watching you with a microscope and
[ __ ] binoculars I hated that [ __ ] if
I look back at my childhood there's the
[ __ ] things I did there's two things I
did the pussiest that I can't even get
mad at people for because I have to live
with this I went on two dates with a
girl that I think grandmother Cuban
grandma and the grandmother sat in
between us let me tell you something
till this day I remember that and if I
knew what I knew now I would have got up
and smack the grandmother and told the
grand and pulled the granddaughter out
of there like narcos did you see my
clothes he used to kick oh yeah a
girlfriend and a Mexican one there he
used to Rafa huh he used to kidnap the
girlfriend that's what I would have done
with it I don't ever want to go on a
date with a [ __ ] chaperone like it
still hurts me today like she's on
Facebook and I won't even be friends
with it yeah yeah just because she made
a grandmother and if she didn't do it
cuz she was all into she was crazy like
me the grandmother in those days you had
asked the mother
yeah then the mother said I can't I'll
have the time the grandma go here and
you're sitting there like your heart on
die that's a guy's your heart dies
chaperones were the reason why I was a
virgin until I was 19 years old oh yeah
you couldn't get rid of no it's
impossible some right but what was
ironic is now if you take a look at your
old girlfriend she's turning to her mom
so right now she looks exactly like a
chapel row the same girl that you dated
you know when she was 18 and you were 18
you know going to high school together
you know in Miami because I've been in
elevators you know and they don't know
that I speak Spanish you know they'll
take a look at me God will hippie with
long hair you know and they start
talking about me they're gonna say we
meet I assume you know Ziggy give me the
meetup Balu you know and then I get off
the elevator and say well when I'm not
just in your nuts you know
no idea you know like your favorite
thing to do a mine if I knew another
language I would just go around trying
to do this but I got a kick out of that
you know because to me leaving Miami was
my second exile you know first I left
Cuba then I went to Miami and that was I
gotta get out of here because it was how
you felt the man oh I still do I can
only take Miami you know I go there to
see my mom like three or four days and
then I I gotta get out what was your
total but I'm totally real time my I I
we arrived in 61 we left in 63 to New
Jersey West West New York you know your
hood then we left in 66 we went back to
Miami again and I was there for like ten
more years until disco came in what
didn't you like about it at that time uh
what I didn't like about it well first
of all you know back in nineteen when I
left miss 7yz was still that mentality
dad you're Cuban you're not supposed to
be doing certain things but I look
culturally 70s was tough there yes Emma
needs to be a Cuban yeah first
generation first generation
yeah was very tough it was their rules
were [ __ ] they had rules then yes a
lot of rules as a big problem I'm
talking about rules I don't want to know
about [ __ ] rules
I had those rules and even they were
even harder on me till I went home and
this is great oh my god the Catholic
school my mom came around and she goes I
don't know I don't want to bang answer
you I'm done so we're gonna do it your
way and if it works we'll do it your way
the minute it doesn't work it goes back
to my wife and that was a communist ik
measures mattress you know for anybody
who doesn't know I mean you know I
didn't I tell stories that I got hit
yeah I got hit but the number one
punishment I was made to do was write
lines
I will not call my mother of [ __ ] you
know I'm not saying I have
then but little things I will not play
ball in the house yeah and I would have
to sit there for hours and the eyes had
to be under the eyes perfectly and the
Wills had to be perfectly Wow and I
would sit there for two three days might
get home from school at 3:00 ate lunch
and go right to the notebook that's it
dead till dinner and have to dinner for
two hours and then my mom would be
waiting for an apology and in my world
there was no [ __ ] apology I write
these [ __ ] minds
they'll apologize that now I felt at
that age but then somebody will come
over and there's Cubans call it they
don't like the wire okay that means they
throw in the towel for you so let's say
I'm mad at mercy and Rudy comes over I
leave the room Rudy search of mercy and
say what's going on with you nothing my
dad they don't listen I grew up with
your dad and Noah is just tell him
you're sorry and you want to keep
writing and I go no and think okay call
your mother Marc come in here and my mom
would come in and I'd have to look at
her to say I'm sorry for breaking the
dolls and she'd gone next time you do
this this is the title thing you know my
daughter lost a jacket at school I give
my my daughter 40 bucks a month to do
the podcast ten thousand week I give a
forty I make a sign paperwork and put it
through the whole [ __ ] you know me I
give it to her an envelope I make it
through the whole deal a motherboard of
a school jacket she wanted a hooded
sweatshirt
she lost her to school the mother
charged the 30 bucks yesterday she's
running for an hour took another piggy
bank that's it that's how I was raised
you know you tell the value of a dollar
so was it was I had rules growing out
where he couldn't and then let me tell
you where there was more rules in North
Bergen
there were unspoken rules couldn't get
in a ring couldn't get a tattoo no long
hair it was very well known in North
Bergen like that the basic rules of
North Bergen
they want written but they were very
basic the kid died about six weeks ago
from North Bergen I'm friends with his
wife today and his wife came to my show
of Rascals and she goes when I hugged
her I know I'm sorry about whatever [ __ ]
my husband always loved you he said you
were a real man because you sophomore
year he broke up with a girl and you
went to him before you asked her out
and I did I stopped me I went to this
talk [ __ ] I go hey you guys have
been broken apart for a month there's a
word on the street that her and I could
click are you okay with this I could see
it he turned pale I think it was I still
love her like all this you're apart for
a month I think goes well you do what
you gotta do I put my hand out I thought
I'm just here to tell you I'm gonna take
her out that they don't want no problem
I put my hand out that's what men did
that's how I was raised like that was
the cold in that town that town was very
coldest you know some kid hit me last
night you know when we were kids we were
raised to do everything the best like we
went to hash ways there was no fast food
you didn't eat at that place but you
didn't step foot in that but you know
that's just the way it is you lived off
discipline a certain discipline and I
carried that discipline out here I come
a regular I'm not a bagel head you know
that you'll never hear me go on the
pizzas I don't care I'm here I'm not
here for the [ __ ] pizza anyway I'm
here for a dream or therefore a not here
for a bagel but when it comes to food
I'm very traditional Cuban you know you
gotta have this [ __ ] somewhere I don't
want it I'd rather not have second best
you know it's like some guy said to me
let's go into the wall
I want to take you to church Popeyes I
wouldn't walk into [ __ ] Popeye I
wouldn't walk in I made a mistake one
time I was sick for four [ __ ] days
I'll never do it again I go I'm a
chick-fil-a guy he goes chick-fil-a's a
better sandwich but don't you want to
taste the Popeyes just to compare it I
go why would I [ __ ] with the best it's
the best it's the best I'm gonna go to
Popeyes and last I want the Popeyes it
took the skin off the chicken like to
see four toes
the breast was a guy's foot you could
see it take a genius I wish I was lying
T it was like a [ __ ] foot that they
had cut at the ankle not at the ankle at
the at the insole and they deep-fried it
that's what it looked like I never went
back in there never again and then my
daughter won in there whenever my I told
my wife I can't bring her in here gee
yeah but it's good that you can't bring
her in here we don't need that [ __ ] we
don't do that we don't we don't ballet
before I say when I was a kid in Cuba in
the 50s the fast food will come to you
we had guys with carts and it would be
like they either had a bell or they had
their brigham which is like their slogan
you know will be singing money said oh
you know selling peanuts or whatever you
know and the best chick-fil-a type
sandwiches buying Ambani so be same
funny so oh boy and bunny saw which is
like breaded brothers breaded right
there made fresh and this little cart
this guy's pushing this cart along the
street you know and he's got it like a
like a grill you know like a like a
hibachi grill Mexicans no yeah yeah that
was her fast food but they don't move -
you know these guys yeah yeah and
they're like yelling out letting
everybody in a neighborhood that he's
common man yeah and and my mom had a
basket with a rope and she would put the
money in there put the basket down with
the rope and the guy would put take the
money and put the the sandwich and she
will take the basket right up and that
that was or you know that was her fast
food you know and it was amazing fresh
and he had soul you know the guy will be
singing along with it you know the
basket hanging out of my window I would
never leave the house it was a balcony
you know they come to you the ice-cream
guy get a nice ow you know where's the
shave eyes you know with that with that
jizz on it and they you know all that
peanuts
boy stirs oyster cart oysters already
prepared with with the sauce and
everything you know
or building out the owning of doing a
theory yeah waster yeah like those [ __ ]
yeah thanks yeah
what Cuban rules didn't you like that
you felt well you know I wasn't as much
as my family had rules it was more I
mean you know my mom had some guide you
know of course you know guidance and
things you can do you cannot do for
example she had the law that if my if my
brother and I we were fighting you know
over anything you know stupid things
like kids do she would hit us with a
belt both not one but whoever whoever if
if you were guilty you're gonna get hit
and I go to yeah you were gonna yeah
everybody got hit so that was like a
main rule you know you know so we didn't
fight over anything you know and you
know but it was more cultural social
rules you know that it that if you went
out into the streets and you were in and
you were facing Miami as a a culture an
extension of Cuba you know you were
still had those rules that they were
applied to you in Cuba but in Miami and
they really did not apply anymore in
Miami you know but because you're it's
part of the United States so it was a I
find it very tough for some people to
assimilate early on first-generation
Cubans my my family for example they had
like a a cut-off point if it was like
across the street from Flagler where
they live
that was Coral Gables they won't go
there because that's Coral Gables they
wanted to live in the northwest a subway
and nowhere you know that was more like
a Cuban Cuban territory so they had that
cutoff you know that was that was the
rule don't go to Coral Gables you'll get
lost
it's a lot of white people there they
were no they're not gonna help you get
back home basically my rules
I couldn't the rules of the house were
meet how are you kaya I was allowed to
repeat what I heard now the three
monkeys were everywhere
all right you know when they cover their
eyes there you know I couldn't do and
then when Juan came into the picture he
brought even more rules because he was
the ultimate machismo Cuban man the guy
that you know he wouldn't be in a room
with a man look that was gay mm-hmm if
he was a man walk then he'd walk exactly
yeah that allowed to drink in public
can't let nobody drink in public married
no flash
you have to confuse the people who you
are yeah let them you know he was always
confused yeah so he brought different
rules into my life you know we weren't
allowed to talk on the phone about
anything like even if I knew something I
wasn't allowed to I'll never forget them
pulling up one day and meat getting into
a beef I had a beat maybe Mercy's age
six and getting into a beef outside in
the cop broke it up and be talking to
the cop my mother comes up to God don't
say two words so [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know you're not allowed to talk to cops
it was like so there were so many
[ __ ] rules
in my house growing up that it was
confusing and I kept to them like I
never repeated the life I was living
inside my house but one of the positive
rules and my mother had was I was not
allowed to speak Spanish outside the
house in the house she wanted me to
speak Spanish she's I stir them us
having that conversation that she didn't
want to raise no [ __ ] Ricky Ricardo
with an accent then yeah accent has to
be American you're an American and you
some of my rules the plan for me was
laid out you know these Arabs
complaining I left because they wanted
me to marry my cousin well I had the
same rules I wasn't gonna marry my
cousin yeah oh no they pretty much had a
woman for me to Mack it was her
goddaughter mm-hmm that was the plan
that I married her goddaughter so they
always pushed us together when we were
kids but my mother's plan was high
school the service and her head see
though because she wanted to give back
to the country
the country had done for her so she
wanted me to do four years then go to
college thing but a law school that was
the plan that's why when I got left back
in the seventh grade I'm like how plans
not gonna work out cuz I can't even make
it out of the seventh grade I'm so
[ __ ] stupid
so that was her plan that was it I knew
in high school that I was gonna go into
the army but she was gonna force me into
the army like there was no way about it
that was her main goal you're given this
country for [ __ ] years for what they
did for us and even though she was the
numbers and she owned the bar as he was
a drunk those were her principles so
it's really weird the rules I had
growing up I couldn't wear my hair a
certain way I couldn't part it what side
do Cubans part they're a Cuban man has
to be yes on the left side yeah if you
partner on the right side that means
you're a [ __ ] so every once awhile I
would experiment with my hair and that
[ __ ] comb it to the right side and I
go to breakfast and she'd go what are
you Rock Hudson no what are you talking
about she's gonna put your hand the
other side boys like you remember in the
70s was poppy that'll wear a scarf with
a little a little ball when you tighten
it sweating in Miami yeah in the 70s
there was a style yeah that you put a
scarf or onion there yeah yeah yeah and
it was just a little circle yeah and you
took the circle put the scars yeah he's
a hippie boy yeah yeah I'll never forget
the first time here I put one of those
things on the living room she just
looked up and she was like what are you
a [ __ ]
take that off right now you're
embarrassing me and I'm saying a [ __ ]
like that like yeah it wasn't a lot like
if you were laying on the floor I was
not allowed to cross my mother's body so
she's laying on the floor okay got my
stomach yeah TV yeah Cubans are lamb
cross the body that means that in a in a
cemetery yeah you have to walk around
them yeah you couldn't say can't the
word cancer in my house yeah my mother
would spin on herself yeah so whatever
something to say cancer should go yeah
put all this up
[ __ ] is wrong we knew it was just so
many basic Walter and I forget happen
like I forget 3/4 of now yeah but there
was just so many [ __ ] rules I had
they were ridiculous yeah I mean I you
know I just like you I love my parents
and I'm grateful for them because
everything that I am today is because of
them you know all the sacrifices and
everything and but there was a lot of
funny [ __ ] you know going on you know is
like when we first got to Miami and then
61 my dad's first thing he got was a TV
was the first paycheck he's sorry and
credit you know back back in the day old
key was that credit you know and credit
cards and stuff and we got a TV and so
on Sunday whenever football came on
television and my mom's say you know we
they have football in Cuba you know
American football you know and she sees
like these guys wearing like tights and
and they're close to each other and one
guy's got his hands on the meet the
other guy's leg to grab a ball she goes
no no no no no kid ok well you know I
want you to watch this this is this is
wrong there was no football in my house
he always been with tight pants and
watch each other no no we don't want
that no I could to see it yeah there was
yeah but she's know was so high even
with mom's mom or yeah out of it because
mom's new to torture the kids were gonna
get if they you know Cuba in the 50s and
40s was very anti-gay and more Fidel too
cold he was even more and I think pretty
much the word the whole world was pretty
anti-gay back then yeah for Cubans I've
read stories of there was a time in Cuba
it was such a disgrace that the
neighbors would talk to parents and to
taking the child shark fishing and
throwing him off the boat you know in
the celeea crew story they killed her
brother or her nephew cuz email hey yeah
you know it was a different time than
Cuba to be gay you know it wasn't like
flamboyant but Rock Hudson went down
every
and was gay in a cube oh yeah they
accept him you know Marlon Brando this
stories about Marlon Brando going down
to Cuba and being gay you know and and I
remember being a kid in hearing Cubans
telling me about different personalities
and I go how the [ __ ] do you know about
this and they go cuz when I was a kid
they would come to Cuba and we were kids
we were following around with Michael
Jackson and Michael Jackson put the kid
outside the window yeah yeah thousand
people outside yeah that's what would
happen in Cuba when like a celebrity
yeah yeah the not sure now or something
like that they would people would get
the word around you know who's ever in
town you know whoever was big at that
time you know Sinatra
you know when Sinatra was at the
National or whatever they were [ __ ]
two hundred Cuban skinny chicks I wait
the suckers that yeah you know he would
pick them and choose you know man if you
read the book of an electorate it talks
about and being in Cuba a lot there's
sexual [ __ ] prowess system that
[ __ ] was going crazy yeah
recently this this man Walter Mercado
yes
died he passed away you know years ago
yeah and you know he was like a big huge
huge presence in Miami in the sixties
you know I mean you took a look at the
guy and we you know all the you know
what was made fun of him you know
because everything his mannerism the way
dress you know yeah and it's obviously
his sexual orientation was not in
question but but when they announced you
know that the local a Los Angeles anchor
person you know was talking about his
background and everything announcing his
passing and and then he mentioned and
and that his lifestyle his sexual
preference was never mentioned they
never came out
and I'm thinking did he have to get my
nose didn't have to come home you know
it's obvious and who cares really you
know another thing going back to that
when I was it when I was a kid you know
I was into music and you know you were a
kid you're going wow you know I tried a
trumpet first and I tried
bounine I was just going down the
instruments you know until eventually I
got a guitar but in between that I
thought maybe piano piano no this sounds
great I can play rock and roll then I
can play you know some classical music
jazz is music you know and my mom would
say oh no no oh no the piano is not for
for man to play but she in here she knew
a lot of you know gain piano players in
Cuba and she thought that the instrument
was going to turn you gay the Cuban
culture thing or was it a Catholic thing
or a mixer like what do you think I
think was reference reference that she
had that [ __ ] because one of my aunt's
was actually a casino lounge singer in
Miami I'm sorry in Cuba in Havana you
know all those casino all those hotels
they had casinos in Havana you know
there was beer that the normal thing you
know so her the guy who that would
accompany her was gay you know the
feeling she got like like like two or
three piano players are what accompany
my aunt and they all gay so my mom's
reference at the time was like well all
these guys that play piano they're gay
so the instrument must turn you gay
don't play piano it was they had the
list of the other night they had a semi
list up of Cuban rules and people were
howling like yeah jump in the pool for a
now and then would stick to the rule and
you're in in Miami at the hotel
trembling you count in the coming going
down no no after you eat like I need a
shower is all the time now I've run
after yeah
the showers I take one I got a sandwich
in my hand [ __ ] died my mom will now
pick up the phone if it's raining in
Miami because there might be lightning
and even if you have a wireless you know
not a cell phone bought a wireless phone
you know cordless phone in your house
she would not pick it up because she
thinks she's gonna collect acute it you
know hit hit hit by lightning
you know rules these are the rules and I
grew up with that you cannot eat you
cannot
going to shower after you eat for so
many hours because you're getting
Columbia which is the a we got a cramp
you better get a cramp and you're gonna
die in the shower yeah yes yes all the
pool
yeah they will the boy and I had the
pool won but the shower one I never had
before they were men she's like no
matter how ridiculous something is my
mama always say to me she will say it
and then she'll go explosively you know
it's possible I think the craziest Cuban
thing I have this law was I was living
in Colorado and Arvada 93 I just moved
back and I reconnected with a friend of
my family's his name was Al cawelo he
could be dead now he was a character
like he took me to see kids I don't even
know it you know he well I see him
you always say you and my ticket is he
kissed I your friends I'll know from his
kiss I don't [ __ ] know you know but
kids were from Long Island they would do
little bars they took me to a rehearse
or one day and he had girlfriends and
you know whatever then I lost contact
with my rekindle my contact with him I
met him selling cars
somebody told he's a human guy from
Jersey it's those cars at Douglas Toyota
song went over them they know what your
naming was Al and we started talking
like oh my god I grew up with you you
know well parents know each other
and he goes you know stay with me so I
moved in with him when I came back from
Jersey and his aunt was coming meet that
wreath I'm and my goal
he had two aunts and I'll never forget
that
we picked the aunt up and she took the
metal tray the pig cut him in half oh
yeah marinade the [ __ ] yeah
and put him on the plane and put him on
top of the plane like like luggage and
the whole plane she goes no no not a
thing are you
and they're talking about the smell of
garlic the other plane was going all
small
yeah they had a Pollux on the plane that
nobody knew about
she didn't say anything it was before
9/11 they won't get it like you know you
take a soldier out of battle she says
they walked on the plane like that just
or this is like hi what are you having
to like luggage we just can't hold them
we arey they had a page and they put the
pig in they took the pig out we drove it
from Denver Airport Coelho thousand they
threw it in the oven and it marinated
for those four hours they were like what
we're gonna do for almost four hours
this marinate the pig let's kill two
birds with one stone
wolf line marinade the pain while they
will [ __ ] fly that's how much respect
they had for that little [ __ ] pig
that's beautiful
I really want to show you talking about
something that made me laugh I enjoyed
it very much I enjoyed it because it
reminded me of what's going on right now
I really like dolomite they reminded me
how lucky I loved Eddie Murphy I've
always loved that Murphy and I don't
want to see him do stand-up or you
[ __ ] idiots that keep pushing for any
Murphy to do stand-up stop it
he hasn't gotten onstage in 20 years
what do you think it's gonna take a year
for him to tune up it's gonna take too
long he makes too much money making
movies and even if they give him seventy
million dollars he does not move it on
to the college don't work out every
night and he's gonna have to and that's
not gonna happen
he's too old he gets [ __ ] of it I've
seen him at the store when you see him
at the store you realize that this was a
stepping stone fan it was a stepping
stone to him this is all this was for
Netflix to give him seventy million
dollars to do a special you'd have to be
an idiot if you're not gonna take it but
I know that Eddie those two specials are
brilliant Roy and delirious he's was he
gonna talk about that what's he gonna do
blow the commies for four nights a week
for a year to hit 60 minutes give me a
[ __ ] breather but beside that little
thing
the dolomite I thought it was great I
thought it was great it's funny he was
talking about that when you started in
North Miami there was a house and see
and he was a black guy I think this a
black guy at every place I did come yet
there was a house yes he yeah I had a
story yeah your guy said that Isaac
Hayes
yeah Jeff Stewart Jeff Stewart was 1969
we were all everybody in the band was
fresh out of high school and we happened
to be rehearsing at the guitar players
house and the father is what his dad
walks in with the newspaper and the
Warner dads page and he says hey there's
this club that's hiring a band they're
looking for a band he just wanted us out
of the house you know up until the time
we were only doing quinceaneras which
was a great breeding ground for rock
bands or you know little bands that
became big you know big musicians came
out of those little bands somewhere in
fact the really me sound
yeah well Miami sandwich in one of them
will leave from David Letterman
Orchestra he was a bass player and one
of the bands in the in the circuit
you know the quinceañeras you know I
mean countless of great musicians came
out of that we had to play a lot of slow
songs because that was the only chance
that that the kids could actually have
body contact while the chaplains were
actually keeping an eye on them you know
on the dance floor you know so they had
this method it was when they're facing
the the chap around they they hold tight
and then when when they go sideways they
separate you know that 6-inch rule right
right and then it was it was over like
that as they go around in circle they
separate and then they come together
again and start humping and then to
separate you know and the more slow
songs you played in your set the more
gigs you got you know so those were the
Miami quinceanera rules you know but
what we went straight from from playing
that circuit into oh listen I had never
seen a naked woman before because all my
girlfriends were Catholic and they had
chapter owns you know their moms all of
a sudden I'm playing in front of naked
women you know don't make it they're
naked you know
what was topless and with the g string
so that might as well be big naked you
know and we had this MC Jeb steward he
looked like Jackie Wilson you know had
the pump of the war you know with a with
the hair grease back matching Romeo
shirt remember those shirts I had like
the big collar and and lace ah yeah yeah
polyester polyester matching pants
usually either orange or light blue baby
blue with with shoes that he every night
he would take paint and spray paint the
shoes to match the color of his outfit
and he had like a like a big cardboard
sign behind the drummer with like
records you know 45 spray painted in
gold and his name in in sequence
you know glitter Jeb store and then he
has some slogan you know like the the
king of soul or whatever and little
musical notes and stuff like that and we
just play Aaron P all night long with
this guy and and he must have been a
great singer at one time but I never got
to hear that because he he had any a
perpetual cold it was always like this
raspy right so he would only hit one
note like I've gone away dog that
midnight hour dah dah dah
you know when this eats you never would
sing a melody it was always like this
raspy one notes singing and he had the
dance moves in between and he was smooth
man slick smooth he will introduce the
girls because you know like he went you
dis a girl and then she would dance
right right in front of us in our little
stage and then she will move on to a
cubicle in this horseshoe shaped bar
with all men sitting around and they had
knockers so instead of clapping that's
what you heard like you know 50 guys
going like this you know in between
girls you know instead of clapping you
know for the girls dancing and the girls
will move around and by the end of the
set you have like eight girls dancing
you know and then that was over and then
15 minutes later you go back
you do another show with the same the
same thing you know yeah that was my my
first club club gig when you on the road
with Whitesnake in 88 87 87 to 94 yes a
let's just say yeah yeah were you ever
on a stage when that having a great
night you know yeah all them everybody's
doing great and at one point you thought
to yourself the reason this is happening
is because what I did in that strip club
absolutely go absolutely I mean I never
dawned on you that [ __ ] destroys me
when I think of the exact moment where I
learned how to do that in half I tell we
it happens to me a lot now when I'm on
stage and I'm controlling the audience
I'm controlling them boy yes and it's
been 28 years but this just didn't
happen that control I learned that a
certain bar in 1995 and while I'm on
stays about the deliver the jokes I'm
well I'm getting my breath back while
they're laughing and they're selling
that daughter just running through my
mind that the reason I'm here right now
is because of that bar in 1995 that
night that the guy threw a steak at me
or whatever you know I'm just making up
scenarios here it's so weird how now 28
years later there's night time on stage
having a good set you know after 20
years of being in it you know thinking
back to the night where you had that
breakthrough that you did that that that
step that maybe you added that baseline
that you know something with me it's
always maybe I move a certain way or I
do something I did something in New
Jersey that I hadn't done in 20 years
like not a bit but a piece from the bit
but I couldn't use the bit anymore
because the biggest [ __ ] old I don't
even think I remember it but I used the
piece and the bit when I got off that
night I go wow I still remember doing
that bit an improv level one night and
then starting to use it and then they
just it was time to read
get rid of the bit and I did but that
little piece of that bit still makes me
laugh and that was that had to be 96 97
when I did that bit to kill time like
somebody said how much time you got him
like 18 dude 30 okay I'll tell a story
and I told that bit this had ever
happened to you that you're on stage you
think back to a certain night
absolutely absolutely yeah you know that
the atomic laught tomboy Club in North
Miami was my first club gig and I kept
playing clubs all the way in Miami up
until like I left in 75 and that was
basically my cutoff point so I was about
six seven years because but it's not
well actually I kept playing and in
clubs up in Chicago area in the Midwest
with another band it wasn't until I got
to LA and in 1978 sorry playing with the
Randy Rhoads version of Quiet Riot that
got yes we were playing clubs but there
were showcase clubs you were expected to
play original material so to me that was
a big difference between playing being
in a cover band because that's not gonna
get you anywhere
you know I mean if you really have
aspirations of becoming a professional
musician you know as far as a career
move yes you might be able to get make
some money and and you know take care of
some bills and things like that but if
you really want to you know make a move
you know it's like it's like in in
comedy or acting you have to you have to
do certain things you know like playing
on a Comedy Store it's a showcase Club
it's not just a comedy gig you're there
with the best of the best you know and
there's gonna be agents they're gonna be
producers and you know the suits are
gonna be in the audience checking out
what's new who who can I get you know
for my next special my next movie or
whatever you know discovering talent
well there are certain clubs and in in
Los Angeles that at the time that was
the purpose of playing there there was
to star would that choir Ryan we were
like a house band there with Randy then
there was that there
the whiskey and the Roxy and the
Troubadour and for one time for a
certain period of time there was bill
gazzarri's gazzarri's place you know van
Halen was like the house band and stuff
like that where was that gazzarri's is
where what does it call now it's called
something else it's it's like a disco
now it was like a Hollywood yeah it's
okay yeah it's it's west of the rainbow
oh so it's down towards that yeah it's
the next club across you know the next
street from from the rainbow Bar & Grill
you know it was all once Jake yeah
playing there was no it's a club called
filthy McNasty which was a cover Club
now is the Viper Room you know really
yeah Viper only should be filter me let
myself be a fool about place on Fairfax
oh wait a minute Gorge towards Wilshire
okay I went there a few times
Irish bar they have like cover bands I
had a friend that was in the yeah duty
band yeah yeah you know the the strip
was like basically the place of course
you know so one later on different clubs
around the area I think it's called the
mint when you're talking about a mint
yes yeah that's another place that open
up later on yeah but hang out what's the
place next to Dan Tana's oh the
troubadour the troubadour hang out
definitely hang out by the time that I
started playing there Quiet Riot played
there without me but yeah that was
almost more folky you know like the
Eagles even a little bit softer rock
Elton John you know perform there it
wasn't kind of like a guitar driven you
know heavy heavier sound like the
whiskey or the Roxy was yeah you know
the Dolomites thing I picked up him and
he set a line in there that he sold he
sold the line so brilliantly and to say
that line you had to be oh yeah in that
some point though I well he's having
dinner
the guy's after the thing and he goes
out take a listen to the whole ball
bah-bah-bah and they said some told me
just paid his money he goes [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
I don't need to talk to you people he
walked out to his car and I think my
collapse came out and he was broke
be cool mmm he goes no you don't know
you don't know what it feels like to
have something that nobody wants mm
that's a point of everybody every
artists career there's a point at the 60
for me it was the five six seven year
mark that you know I'm doing comedy with
these guys I'm in the same circle people
are talking to them but they're not
talking to me you know at one point you
actually go home and go obviously
they're not buying what I'm selling you
know do I keep doing what I'm doing do I
quit do I change my act went there so
Thailand make rocket ship to fly out of
my ass all right
what do you do Jim I'm saying it yeah
and I like that part that they showed
the character pulling it together
nobody family out yeah you know and it's
funny because my whole comedy and I told
especially since I've been working with
Lee I don't even wanted anything perfect
I came from the 70s where I grew up on
calmly Alps whether it was Pryor or
Cosby a Karlin or whatever we were and
it was a different feeling it was six of
us would chip in and get $25 worth of
weed and we get a six-pack of beer and
we come to Rudy's lick garage because
Ruby's parents would work till six
during the week so we would go with at
four o'clock we'd all sit in a circle
and put this comedy album on and giggle
it was like huh it was a thing people
did it wasn't surprising for somebody to
call you in the 70s and go leave what
he's doing Saturday night
bring over onion dip I'm having 20
people over we're gonna listen to the
Bicentennial [ __ ] and he would all sit
there there was a Netflix there was no
comedy special there's no Comi special
you came in with that
fresh she opened it up you took it out
every as I care its mission pride
Bicentennial Megan you put that thing
her and nobody said a [ __ ] word all
you did was laugh nobody said a word and
that was big in the 70s that's why I
went when it came to doing the podcast I
really enjoyed it because it made people
listening it well I used to be in those
rooms nobody said [ __ ] you can't do [ __ ]
today without somebody saying something
messing something up in the 70s nobody
said [ __ ] you put that out of mine
nobody had the heart to say that you
watch the knick game when it's night
nobody you shut your mouth and you hung
on and you listened and not everything
was perfect the recording was weren't
perfect you know even when you listen to
Judas Priest unleash Denis those
recordings weren't imperfect and how
many [ __ ] bootleg albums that they
sell probably bootleg hours I listen to
that were made at the Garden some guy
would walk them with it with a cassette
in his jacket Sean there's no microphone
all these people oh we have to put live
mics and all this [ __ ] what are you
talking about I've seen them do it with
nothing what are you talking about the
first album I ever signed was a guy that
Randy and I Randy Rhoads and I run into
it is 1981 we're at the Atlantic City
Boardwalk and the guy has just bought
the the furs Ozzy ray or broadcast live
you know we're playing life and it
became bootleg let's go bat head soup
and the guy give it gives it to us and
says oh man can you sign this you know
you know what's a bootleg but we were
proud that somebody care to buy this
thing of us playing in it you know that
was that I'll never forget that moment
you know and you know you kind of like
know that okay I'm you know we're on the
on the right path here doing this you
know one of the things that what
dimension about you were talking about
records back in the day you know when
you're a kid yeah okay when I was a kid
in New Jersey this is like in you know
mid 60's
you know you're always looking for
inspiration and there's so many there's
so many Spiegel catalog pages they
you can look through you know the
underwear section whatever when you were
kid you know and so I was always
checking out what when my mom and dad we
go to work and I would stay at home come
home from school I would go through my
dad's stash just to see what what he's
got and I came across this these
collection of records that he had look
they were cold there was a central
character Juana la loca and you know she
what do you call that a woman that
always have to have sex a but yeah yeah
yeah one of those right so that that was
her condition whatever wherever she went
on these records you know there was a
series of records you know let's say she
went to buy a bed that a furniture store
where she points out having sex with in
person I would listen to him yes yeah
yeah but this is something that my dad
would not play when we were right now he
that was a stash you know you know it's
so that that that was a really good
source another source was actually he
had a collection of Betty Betty Page
movies I'm talking about actually having
to me when they're out of the house I
know I got like maybe half 1/2 hour
window to do this set up the projector
screen you know that it's folding you
know set up the projector put on the the
reel and watch it and then put it back
everything exactly the way it was is you
know so it's you know it's a matter of
fact and now what if there if I hear
projector sound magazine oh yeah wait
six day we got a delivery oh yeah the
kid when I was just the stress factory
kid Michael especially ow
he was the oldest one of our crew he had
me by a year he's 57 if I'm 56 to 57 and
we were talking about that when he came
in the greenroom
we put the [ __ ] screen up in my attic
and we had to put like cover the windows
yeah and you put a blanket on the wall
and and there weren't like porno from
today it was like just basement
disgusting mind-altering what's that big
thing everybody's got played TCS D with
PTSD brought you automatically got PTSD
from [ __ ] listening to these things
like from watching them it wasn't like
you looked at women differently it was a
complete different it wasn't like robust
women with big tits they were just like
skanks on the street on fire and then
they would pay a much more $50 to have
sex with them and as a 13 year old a 12
year old when you wait six weeks to
actually see pornography and it is just
a [ __ ] animal show that's exactly it
was it was just a [ __ ] animal show it
really was it was the worst thing I had
ever seen
I still have memories of the chick lane
then she's like non non heroin and also
you see a guy walk into the screen with
his dick and she's like on the drugs
looking at his dick and you could hear
directly go and suck it suck it like you
can hear director and we're like sitting
alone what
suck it we don't even know about a
[ __ ] I'm just so young we knew
something happened like I had heard
about [ __ ] I tried to get the the
[ __ ] my babysitter to suck my dick
when I was six for twenty dollars but I
had never seen like this and she just
kept looking at the guy's dick weird and
then she'd smell it a little bit on the
end of all of us like yeah and then she
put in her mouth and it was bad dick she
can't make him with faces or something
and then she wouldn't get up I she was
like handicap this up like they she got
hit by car
oh do the magic wand on the ground
objectively on me to him this was beyond
me to those directly sure they got
thrown under the jail you know you're
lucky you know like when you see porn
they go to pick her up there was a bit
with them yeah after they make that he
tried to pick her up she's like I'm not
going anyway play she had no legs
oh my god then they gave her two pieces
of bread I will never forget this that
one minute she was sitting there looking
at the dick and it was just a cold at it
right then I know don't even worry about
the flow like next thing you know she
was sitting with a hand like this and
the next thing she had two pieces of
ripe bread of the hand and a jar of
Miracle Whip with a knife in it and
we're like what's she gonna do I'm like
no maybe she's taking a break maybe
she's hungry
she took the Miracle Whip put it on the
bread and then put it on his dick and
put it on his dick it's delete the white
bread off his dick and we were in shock
like all of us stood there like with our
jaws drop and there was a young kid I
wrote a joke about this but this is not
a joke this is a true story there was a
young kid that started crying like he
was like if I was 13 he was 11 or 10 and
also he was like no that's how much you
[ __ ] this up
everybody want their money back people
were pissed off at me cuz it was like 20
bucks and you got three super 8 films
who super 8 and the projector you had a
bill to project it you had a like what's
that beep but right outside that [ __ ]
car was there for a year finally [ __ ]
you had to like put the wing on to the
projector screw it on yeah yeah but it
came in a little box very discreet yeah
and you open it up and you [ __ ] know
was their crimes in there that sounds
terrible that's what it crimes in there
you get those porno 3 you can see the
[ __ ] you can sue the company for PTSD I
wish I still had that portal I would
take it back I just I use this make you
feel when you're [ __ ] 13 it'll ruin
you
I wanted you know I did your radio show
and I went up and did the podcast today
I got carsick going up your hill and
nineteen [ __ ] left turns I was
carsick I had to sit on a bench out in
front of his house and you've always
said that uh you know you were very
happy when you did the podcast I gave me
the inspiration well you inspired me to
do something I'm really thankful I
started going up
I want the two concerts in three months
I want another one and November another
one the sentiment I want to see Guns and
Roses at the Palladium Wow I say yeah I
saw your post yeah and then with the see
Pat Benatar at the Saban theatre yeah
which is [ __ ] great that whole
theater yes you yeah and there was just
what you said I didn't spring the night
on you for the stones I'm happy I did
that and he had a lot of good reviews
mm-hmm I have a lot of friends that are
honest they're not regular white people
that paid 900 number they who pays
man-hunting there's an Italian the
concert suck nobody they gonna think it
was a phenomenal go spend the 900 so you
feel as shitty as I do yeah but my
brother won he's been to see the stones
21 times and they said it wasn't no
point to melon and then I would have
felt bad about I don't like seeing
people like that he but Guns N'Roses is
a [ __ ] experience really yeah it was
really an experience you know reminded
me of it reminded me of Ozzy at the
Palladium in New York well I had that
same had that same dirty Nitti
you know feeling to it yeah you know
Guns N'Roses as that with a Palladium in
New York naturally Etna
like when Guns N'Roses walks in the room
that feeling comes over you but the
Palladium in New York had that grungy
rock and roll dirty you might get
syphilis if you touch the floor with
your finger and finger somebody feel to
it I had a lot of good times yeah having
Palladium that was but I thank you very
much
oh sure to be an entertainer you have to
be entertained time
interesting yes attained yes when you
get bored and I didn't notice as a
comedian till I was already in the game
ten years 11 years but that's why they
say it's important like to watch a movie
once a week for two hours to take your
mind out of the game and get entertained
you know I found me as a comic I learned
a lot from watching singers a singer in
a comic was the same thing would just a
conduit for the message do you know I'm
saying I think you guys have tougher
jobs dad damn you say oh yeah I wouldn't
[ __ ] trace my job for a singer dr.
bill is there's too many things that
could go wrong you guys don't have the
drum solo you guys don't have like the
guitar player going off on a tandem
extending his guitar solo and you're
going like this you you don't have for
example like like if you if you if your
voice is a little bit rough you give the
crowd the mic to sing you'll give the
crowd the mic to finish off your joke
you can't do that you're going to stand
there basically the way the way that we
use issues we look at it you're standing
there you're naked with your dick in
your hand and that's all you got that's
it nothing in between nothing nothing to
shield you nothing to protect you you
know like the other guys in the band
like you only feel a little bit rough
today so I'm gonna like take it you know
now that I ever do that but I but I've
seen singers you know it's it's tough
being a singer it's I think it's
extremely tough I have a cook if I have
a call of my stomach doesn't feel good I
just go there and play because I'm using
my hands you know and I'm gonna move
around and if I really you know wants a
good pass the point of like I'm on stage
now I forget about how shitty I feel
offstage you know if I if I have a cold
or whatever I just go there and play
then I'll probably feel like [ __ ] again
once again of the stage but you you you
got nothing you're just gonna go there
and do it and be a thousand percent
because to that audience that showed up
that's the moment they don't care how
you got there they don't care how you
feel you're gonna deliver and you're
gonna deliver it as good or better than
the last time they saw you and if they
never seen you before you got to live up
to the hype and beyond that that's crazy
it is
I see singers and I'm like wow I learned
different things from different singers
from watching including the axel axel I
did learn a lot from but you know I
loved watching it on BB King sings ya
know he's there yeah yeah he's right
there he's Dino but so are you when when
yours I know you know something that's a
50-50 chance that strengthing was the
longer you do stage the longer that you
are in the game you put yourself there
in time to time now when I go up there
it's like Anthony Robbins says you touch
your shoulder and it's a reaction yeah
it'll give your mind every action on how
to perform yeah you know with that deep
hypnotism or isn't it like you touch
your wrist you know did it means no time
for me as a comic I think that it took a
long time but not like 70% where I could
really depend on my confidence I got a
question for you we musicians we call it
we play that's what we call making music
performing we play what do you guys call
it you're doing comedy see it's it's
different
see we play we we we don't take it well
I mean we take it seriously because you
know we I spent hours playing but but
but I play I spend hours playing because
I love to play that's another thing you
you don't spend at home you don't sit in
the sofa you know throwing lines out you
know we were telling jokes or things
like that no I sit in the sofa watching
TV I got my little dog in between me and
my wife I got a little amplifier that's
not louder than the TV speakers and I'm
playing all night long and I'm I got
ideas coming through my head and I
them meanwhile I'm watching TV you know
what I mean
it's a constant with me I'm always
playing if unless someone on a plane
then I can't play but then I take out
you know my iPad and I look at I start
reading music you know sheet music or
other tutorials you know things like
that's I'm always in it
oh no I'm always in a you I know you are
I'm always in it because as long as my
eyes are open I'm writing yeah I know
you are I'm taking in Donna I'm taking
in data my eyes are always taking in
data as a comic I'm not I might not be
playing but I'm taking him data yeah
yeah and now because I'm more
disciplined than ever and everything now
I know to write that thought down mm-hmm
write it down
yeah I remember let it write it down I'm
getting more success with that right
yeah take the tumor that's run it down
yeah if it even means writing the joke
out because it's not gonna come to you
again you know I put an over thought
once a week yeah no but Thor's red light
therapy you lay there you know many
times I ain't going there baked out of
my mind I think the [ __ ] a whole bit
yeah now I just take a notebook with me
I take a little pad with me when I go to
Nova Thor and I'll loosen the goggles
I'll get the red light beams my eyeballs
and I'll write the [ __ ] thing and I
won't be able to see for an hour after I
leave there I don't give a [ __ ] you know
your eyeballs are when you're a comedian
should always be working that's why you
need to get out of the house that's why
you need to do certain things because
you're collecting data doesn't matter
doesn't matter where you're going a
friend the earth tells you this diner is
good go there yeah sit sit at the bar
watch I'm always watching I was raised
to watch because my mother had the
numbers operation so my eyes had to be
better than everybody else I had to make
sure at that car why is that car there
why is that white car parked there
that's where the Red Death for Rudy
parks every day I was raised to walk
home a different route so some days I
walk up to hunger some days I walk up
Colfax some days I woke up lower okay
just to see what's going on in that
[ __ ] neighborhood so when you're a
comedian your eyes are always collecting
data that's where your comedy comes from
calmly is how your world collides with
the rest of the world why are you not
taking in data whether it's a concert
whether it's a [ __ ] museum maybe to
walk down the block maybe it's a walk in
Hollywood to see a bomb and a funny
story you take a walk in Hollywood
you're always looking off with a funny
stalk you park your car by on me but
going on me but and then take a walk
around their neighborhood right that
neighborhood go to [ __ ] the hamburger
place and get a hamburger like a normal
person
I started going for the black joint and
getting chicken taking others you go
right up the corner there they have all
the food on that block you want just
walk on that block and see what that
block is about you'll get a [ __ ]
you'll get a [ __ ] minute or two of
material so we're always working
yes I'm musicians what I meant to say
from the singers is like Robert Plant
the song remains the same his whole body
becomes a weapon in that that movie if
you watch his whole body it's his whole
body is giving you material that's very
real I know that that's very rude I'm
not too many [ __ ] Saint else had that
some singers could connect with the
audience some singers could take you
there and some [ __ ] sing is all
there but right there there but you're
going into something really interesting
and and another major difference from
what we do as musicians than what you do
take rubber plant outside of Led
Zeppelin it's not the same Led Zeppelin
it's like for example when I play with
certain bands when I play with Ozzy I
would I feel like an animal on stage
when I play with Quiet Riot I was more
it was more joyful it was funnier it's a
whole different emotion that I get when
I play with Whitesnake you know I was
[ __ ] licking the bass all over the
place because I felt it you know there
was a sexual undertone to it you know
then I play we do and it was more like
that super heavy metal you know you know
with deal he would hit certain notes
Ronnie that I was standing next to him
and I will just levitate on stage it was
like holy [ __ ] it was like you know we
did the song gates of Babel long and he
wouldn't hit this certain note and it
was like wow I was actually really off
the ground you know so it's it's it's
very different what I'm trying to say is
that you only as good as the band that
you're in in your case yeah in your case
is you have no choice but to be good no
matter where you go because you're not
in a band you're the ultimate solo
artist and you got to maintain that
level you're not going from Led Zeppelin
to deep purple to L'Ecole son you're
going solo and you're doing all the
material and things like that your level
of intensity is it's at top level no
matter what you do because you're not
you're you you're not the the the singer
in one band that's going with another
band that then it's a whole different
trip another from vibe or a different
energy different music it's about
something else you know what I mean so
with you is tougher much tougher because
you don't have that role to play even
though we're live well we're really
characters in a play and the play
happens to be that band I was talking
with someone yesterday I'd be interested
to see what you guys think because when
you start start playing music I imagine
that you're focused on playing it right
at the beginning and where I am in
comedy I'm focused on telling the jokes
the way I want to tell them and I see a
lot of comedic Joey and other guys they
are really great performers like only
they can really there's another level
when you have the basics down and you
can actually get animated or lick the
bass like how long does it take for you
to like do exactly and that and that's a
really great topic because this is
another thing that that that it's
different from you
musicians and on what Joey does you know
with it stand up you know it's is the
fact that when we traditionally will
move a going tour we make a record are
you making a record and just like you're
getting opinions from not only your
bandmates you're getting a penny from
yourself you know you start thinking
about okay what am I gonna play in this
song you know in the studio
you've got pre-production you go in the
studio so working with a producer and
they say well change it a little bit
because it's not suitable worth with
everything else going on so it goes
through filters and filters and it's not
until you're our own stage after the
records been released
you've been two weeks on the road you
look at the audience you look at the
guys in the band that that song that new
song really you understand the meaning
of that song you go and now I know what
the song is about so now you're really
playing the song that case in point how
many how many live albums have you heard
that you think wow the [ __ ] sounds way
better than it did in the studio you
know makes because now the pan gets it
the band oh this is what the song is you
know not in the studio when you
basically the studio is like a
laboratory you're on the under the
microscope every single note is being
questioned by the producer by the artist
relations guy that is the executive
producer of the record and and the
singer and the guitar player and who let
the drummer everybody everybody is
looking at what you're playing you're
looking what everybody else is playing
we're analyzing everything when you're
on stage for a couple of weeks touring
that song you're not analyzing you were
become that song and along with the
audience because you got the audience
see to me the audience have always been
like like a like a dashboard in a car
you're looking at the tachometer if
you're going you know sure you go to the
next shift to the next speed you know go
from like second gear to third gear or
bring it back a little bit in the middle
of the set because you don't want to
blow up the engine you want to go full
tilt all the way because that's just
gonna explode you know so you've got
like shifting gears through
the whole set you I'm sure you do that
live you look at the audience you
getting the feedback and you know what
to hit him with next next yeah I can
have a set list one other ten I'm gonna
stick to that Seth listen I'm I still do
all the jokes in that service but when I
get on stage everything comes to life
it doesn't call for that setlist
something happened before me that has to
make me adjust that setlist so I have to
call what the quarterback squall
inaudible that that's beautiful that
joke comes to an absolute I really enjoy
sitting down and writing the core of a
joke but after 20 years I've realized
that the tag isn't gonna be written on
stage whether I like some of that I'm
funnier when I'm under pressure when I'm
under pressure especially on the workout
nights like tonight you know last night
at the store I go down there with no
pressure it's not about me it's about me
trying everything in that Arsenal that I
wrote from from Sunday to last night I
must have made four or five little notes
little adjustments oh I get it now
like I'm not sitting there anymore
waiting to write a 20 minute bit on
paper it's not gonna happen
sorry but it's so weird because the
first live album I ever bought was get
your Yaya's up and I listened to it and
I gave it away the next day I thought it
was garbage because I didn't like
cobblestones every song sounded
different mm I didn't like that I wanted
it to sound the same mm then I put on
unleash the beast
I had already bought the first Judas
Priest album and I had another hound by
Judas Priest stain class I think I don't
know what I had at that time I'm lying
to you guys
I knew Jewish priests was I didn't have
any other grounds I had heard one of the
I was at my friend's house one night
when I heard there live unleashed in the
east I didn't like it at first again
we're going away from the plant but then
I was like wait a second this sounds
better
diamonds are rust my Joan Baez sounds a
lot better life but it doesn't the [ __ ]
up studio yeah you know victim of
changes yeah
sounds a lot better and then I started
getting into more live recordings I was
buying more bootlegs and I was
understanding what was happening till
you said that and didn't really clarify
at all I never knew they had that
knowledge then it becomes one when
you're out there yeah like I when I went
to see you at the Palladium with Ozzy
you guys did it this is a song coming
off the new M which is flying high again
yeah you think you did flying high get
out of that set there was no diary of a
madman no no no no there was flying high
yeah unbeliever dozen song called it
from dying yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
but they're so weird I've never really
thought about that way yeah me myself
like I've had Joe Cory on here jo koy
does not leave his house turn away mmm
he does all his writing on the Rope mmm
he makes people pay 25 hours 35 hours 45
minutes brilliant I don't like it but
then again why that the audience loves
it yeah plenty of times I come hold him
to Comedy Store and I run in that room
just to write three words down yeah
three words now the sentence not a joke
not a bit three words some words that
have to change some way and there should
be six but I only remember three so I'll
take the three for right now I remember
the other three when I go back to the
store on Tuesday on Thursday night
though I'll give you another one how
about the difference of why it's a
tougher for you than it is for us
musicians rubber plant let's say you're
going to watch him solo somehow he's
gonna do a version of a whole lot of
love because otherwise you feel like
you've been ripped off right he did
you're right here and I from December
1988 what was the last time you did that
people came to see you because they're
expecting to hear a certain joke you
know a certain line that you delivered
twenty years ago ten years ago you got
to come up with new material all the
time we don't we do is my fact people
don't even want to hear new material
that's why a lot of bands don't even
make new records we don't they want to
hear the hits so imagine if you get up
on stage every night you say the same
jokes your biggest jokes and that's what
people are lining up for you I mean we
all have our greatest hits if you go to
each one of your specials or your albums
you're gonna have one memorable bit if
it's really old I will throw it up but
you never know you know where you're
gonna go there's bits that aren't on CDs
for the road but I never put on a CD
enough they're just sitting there
waiting to get morphed in toward another
joke exactly morphed Moria well how I
have it a minute and a half this o ad
yeah two and a half more minutes that
joke that bits been sitting the wings
yeah yeah yeah wait no some yak a
[ __ ] yeah so no that whole
process I love now like guarantee why
you guys are on state I'll tell you
who's a band that I liked because
they're live performances and because
everything sounded different you
wouldn't expect it from me but I lived
in Boulder and I listened to them a lot
or voluntarily you have to listen to the
dead
all right dead yeah yeah you live in
Boulder yeah everybody's playing at that
next door downstairs and everybody don't
play the out they play the bootlegs from
the Oakland shows and the Oklahoma show
yeah so you get to listen to like three
nights at the Oklahoma Superdome I don't
know if this is what it's called I'm
just making up a name so you get to see
how they switch I mean that how they
grow or that how they manipulate every
night maybe tonight want to do this
maybe tonight Jerry Garcia plays this no
maybe time Jerry Garcia there's a long
solo depend on which heroin he didn't if
he had a piece of chocolate candy
whatever the [ __ ] that's what I really
admired that I know one thing I got I
want to see calm and I always tell this
because I'm missing forms and times
I want to see calmly one time before I
got on stage two times before I got on
stage in those two times I was not
thinking about doing comedy I just went
to accompany a friend of mine and they
were both the same comedian because he
was a big fan and this is way before I
got into comedy
the first time I saw him was like
October let's just make up a date maybe
October now let's say maybe January of
87 and then the next time I saw was
jeweled of 88 and I'll never forget that
he didn't write a new joke at all he did
the same routine he had done the 14 once
prior to that and I'll never forget as a
[ __ ] cokehead lost Coquette not even
a comedian I wasn't even comedy wasn't
even on my radar and we're walking out
going hmm that's interesting that he
said the same material either a year ago
if that was me I would never do that
this is way before a common way before
Carly I paid to allow us to go see Led
Zeppelin I better hear a whole lot of
love I want to hear I have a set list of
songs I want to hear but I know I spoke
to a Mexican friend of mine and he said
he went to see Santana and he goes I
should have taken the two miles and
ripped it in half because all he does is
introduce new music and talks about his
political you know and what his
aspirations are or whatever and then
people were yelling oh yeah come on
Vaughn yeah oh no no no I'm gonna do
this acoustic get the [ __ ] out here we
want to hear [ __ ] so black my black
magic woman Soul Survivor
they came to here yeah so he didn't do
well you know my people just didn't the
reviews were bad I could see that me as
a when I went to see guns are the weird
thing about Guns N'Roses was that Monday
and
truncation a guy called in a very
intelligent guy you know usually you may
hit wrong nation oh yeah I call it I
know Eddie yeah the people that call in
to trump nation not just right hey man
how you doing
let me ask you something where did it
happen - man - spiders there were a
small man you like the spiders guy live
it up go hang yourself you only saying
the guy's just calling what happened and
they try to be swarming yeah like man
listen man my favorite do Rudy Sarzo
Verne I want to see him recently and I
do you know like they just try to be
swarming and he [ __ ] him up and he
[ __ ] them up good but a guy called and
it was very intelligent he was know all
these people but I paying all his money
to see guns and roses do music that was
put out in 1988 to do whatever and my
daughter and my wife went in to bully
buster and I sat outside listening to
the argument about and I'm like you know
maybe maybe not you know I don't know
how I feel about this argument but I
thought about that too if I'm paying
four dollars for a ticket I want to hear
something know especially if it's guns
and roads it's got to be good that two
days later I got the call I go see Guns
N'Roses that Monday like that Wednesday
they called me go we got two tickets for
you to go see done the runs at the
Palladium Saturday if you wanna go I'm
like [ __ ] yeah I go now I'm here let me
tell you something when they played the
beginning of it could be mine you could
be mine the place almost blew up you
know
November rain the place home whatever
that's what you wanna hear like I was
there I'm right there by the plane over
Moraine they played better play this
song here yeah but but I can tell you
this as a fan and as a professional
musician songs are just triggers your
mind triggers like so somebody you know
so let's say especially playing in Los
Angeles they're an LA band so when they
hear you know you should be you could be
mine people Rameau STUV the audience
actually saw them playing at the whisky
or saw them back in 88 they were part of
the whole Sunset Strip so
you just basically triggering this
emotion of like [ __ ] yeah man you know
like 30 years before right and all of a
sudden they are 19 again they're writing
their Harley's they gather their
motorcycle jackets on and and and just
not a care in the world so they just
losing their shared because they're
being transported to that place in time
I know that because it happens to me as
a fan I've been a fan longer than have
been a professional musician so till I
got a whole catalogue of music they just
[ __ ] me up every time I hear who you
know and some of them I'm actually
playing you know I mean I grew up I was
a kid when I was listening to the
guess-who songs like these eyes used to
be like this yeah yeah don't don't
and that song was like the favorite song
of this you know when you were a kid you
have a girlfriend and you have like you
afraid your song your favorite song and
that was like a crazy girlfriend that I
had that was a favorite song so I'm here
I'm onstage with the band playing that
song and all I can do is just laughs I'm
laughing I'm smiling yeah I'm happy
because I'm playing that song but I'm
also laughing at at the at the at the
irony of the whole thing that I'm
actually in the band blamed the song
that was not only our song it was also a
breakup song you know what's a breakup
song boy you know it's a song that
happened to be playing on the radio when
when the chick breaks up with you that
was your last memory of the song and
saying thank you thank you for breaking
up with me because otherwise that would
probably been married you have like 20
grandchildren by now and be in Miami
playing in it you know it playing congas
and it isn't a Nibbana [ __ ] or Miami
Sound Machine trivia - I did not know -
Wendy was alien yeah that you and
Ronnie's last band right Ronnie yeah I
was his life's last bass player in deal
yeah I was in the band from 2004 until
he passed away in 2010
yeah 2010 yeah you were tour the whole
thing why didn't I love running
I love Ronnie I be
yeah because you never asked me about I
knew you had done something Revati oh
god yeah I just meant I love it all we
looked it up and I was like wow I didn't
know that yeah yeah we did the record
together the what is it 2020 80 or 25th
year anniversary of Holy Diver we did
the whole the whole record
and and there's a DVD of that if I find
one at home I think I have an extra copy
all I'll bring it to you
83 Holy Diver tremendous Holy Diver yeah
yeah yeah it was the twenty five four
year anniversary of Holy Diver yeah who
was a drummer on that out on the record
was Vinny Appice a time person who I
play with him in Black Sabbath right and
then when Vinny left the band Simon
Wright from ac/dc took over yeah no
Simon was the second drummer in ac/dc he
was like 16 17 years old when he joined
the band yeah [ __ ] tremendous really
just think Thursday tomorrow yes
Thursday is the stand up and shout
bowling event over a pins in in Sherman
Oaks or cities so you see my behind
Jerry's deli Terry's deli you a bunch of
people I'm gonna be after the Foo
Fighters yeah Eddie trunk is ready true
good thing yeah I mean I'm in Detroit I
already sold out and I had to cancel it
once yeah so it's nothing I could cancel
again trust me I would love to be able
to go to this board there's other events
that happened through the years right
she's invited me to 2020 February 20th
yeah they have the motorcycle rally and
all that which I show up with a [ __ ]
boat yeah they were making some some
major strides as far as cancer goes you
know there's a lot of Hope there Frankie
Banali you know our my Mike well I mean
he's not only my my Quiet Riot drum you
know the rhythm section partner but he's
we I grew up playing with Frankie back
in Florida in 72 so 11 years before we
were playing together in Quiet Riot
I mean I was playing with him you know
so he was the best man at my wedding so
you know we're we're we're brothers you
know and recently he came came a made an
announcement that he had Stage four
pancreatic cancer but I gotta tell you
you know I knew about it months before
that and every day we were texting and
hey what a fighter why to fight
constantly having chemotherapy and other
alternative medication and and he's
playing he's back playing again you know
anything which is what he was born to do
you know and it's amazing because this
gives hope to a lot of people because
usually Stage four pancreatic cancer
you're done you're done
no he's not done he's not done easy see
like some Iraqis I can say that once it
once he goes through the whole thing
completely he'll be stronger and better
than ever
yeah yeah no I donated I told her yeah
don't a little so I donate a little
something - yeah a little something
because she's doing a good cause yeah
running a scam absolutely absolutely so
you know there's this is you know brings
up a lot of hope to people you don't
give up don't give up because you know
the longer you stay in the game the
better medication is gonna be discovered
you know better treatments and things
like that so it could be that in that in
very short period maybe in a couple of
years cancer will be eradicated you
don't want that yeah but it's gonna work
yeah nobody wants it that's a
multi-billion dollar II and wellness you
know but located here is the cure is the
cure cure is evidence so yeah exactly
exactly
why are you playing solo you're doing
the camp doing repla fantasy camp next
week we we got cheap trick coming in
we're recreating Sergeant Pepper
life at The Whisky A Go Go what date
November 17 the day before my birthday
November 18th is your birthday I'll be
16 hours a day I kidnapped a fella
at the kidnap now I remember your
birthday every 1469 and you're only 69
once that's it but you could do it
forever it's the only age you once but
you could do it for every time same and
you can start young you've tried it
before
69 sniffing a little as always not even
perfume it's not a bad time
anyway this weekend Detroit is sold out
Omaha the tickets are gone me and Dean
Delray and I got a call yesterday Miami
sold that's all I got left for you
[ __ ] is December 6 the second
show at the New York town hall 10:30
show 35 our tickets no [ __ ] drama
you'd listen one thing I noticed about
this week is last night I was watching
the giant game it was midnight they were
still the stadium was packed [ __ ] New
York is a late town man la they die like
[ __ ] here at 8:30 in New York you
gotta kill him at 3:00 3:00 is like that
yeah night they're in the UFC one in the
morning they were all still there that
fight was won the [ __ ] morning it
tried to an event center at 1:00 in the
morning over here at Staples Center
those people [ __ ] melt the building
or melt if they go on a triple overtime
awakens or something like that but
that's all I got for you [ __ ]
Rudy what's going on with the podcast in
the show I got the other shows every
Sunday on bunches of rock radio we got
to get you in one of those cruises no no
go on it's a bands and rock and roll you
know and goofy [ __ ] creepy questions
in the daytime
piece of cake my wife's over there died
from diabetes
Kokila once and for all you gotta bother
me with this pothead Cruz relationships
I I haven't done the the muscles of Rock
cruise yeah because you know the with
against who we do the flower pop which
is sixty years old I mean you know in
sixty sixties a cruise you know people
that were around in the 60s and then the
next one is the the rock and romance
which is 270 screws and I got to tell
you it's it's it's it's really a trip I
really imagine that it really is I just
don't want to be on the boat with nobody
how many days is it no actually it's not
too bad because what they do is they
they split the cruise with two shifts of
bands so if 30 bands are playing it and
the whole cruise the first 15 were bored
and let's say in Fort Lauderdale and
then get off in Jamaica then the next 15
born in Jamaica the flight to Jamaica
and then disembark in full auto bill so
not all 30 bands are on board the ship
at all times so you only have that
you're there like maybe three or four
days tops
yes not bad at all I don't know three
more days I want to be anyway especially
walking around in circles with his ship
like I said I'm a big fan heavy trunk
and while I'm a big fan of the trunk is
because he tolerates a lot I'd hang up
half those people can you imagine you
know one day they're gonna take them off
the ship in a white suit on one of those
jackets going I haven't seen Ronnie
Montrose I haven't you know they just
drive him crazy
I can't imagine those people on the tour
just when you're eating breakfast I
don't want to bother you but my aunt
what was the laminate guitar playing and
ritchie blackmore second band I'm gonna
Trump trunk what are the members dumped
yeah yeah listen you stumped me again
and I'll stab you with this flashlight
yeah well they gather in [ __ ] maple
syrup on it you follow him on Twitter
because yes it's the same thing on
Twitter like all these people like
asking him questions he he he's he's my
idol yeah his patient yeah he's great
it's great I have a good good chance of
staying out of prison because right now
I can't take it no more one of these
[ __ ] is eventually gonna get
stabbed it's probably gonna be me no you
got you all right you'll be on the
standpoint I throw your guys I gotta
take you at El Camino Island what's the
island down here in California yeah
we're gonna have a good time I got
Sunday's for you don't worry about none
they got a big banana [ __ ] float
waiting for you
Catalina I'll throw you right over we'll
get it I'll stab you with a needle the
shark will come real quick and turn you
away don't worry about not getting the
insurance policy I'm gonna cut your mom
in for the small 20 just so you know
buddy I gotta get the 80% I'm working
I'm doing all the lifting in the museum
thing thank you for that I love you
mother [ __ ] this really Sarzo thank you
very much
listen to Rudy I'm monsters of rock
radio support them follow a month
Willie's got agree does a great job on
Twitter the [ __ ] I love you
[ __ ] and the rest of you savages
I'll see you Thursday night in Detroit
ready to blow that [ __ ] place
up listen I don't have nothing left from
my youth I just got one thing left yes
they posted my grammar school can you
please if you have any report cards or
t-shirt from grammar school I said
listen go [ __ ] yourself I never saved
the thing from that school but I have
one thing I have a shirt that a friend
of mine gave me in 1987 that says
Detroit the murder capital of the world
there's some [ __ ] no more there was a
murder capital United States oh yeah and
I'm going to Detroit and then I'm going
on my Honda Brassica to get some piece
of steak with me down rate so I'll see
you [ __ ] dead or not we'll see
you next Tuesday tip-top Magoo ready to
stab a [ __ ]
I love you guys don't forget Miami and
probably sold out
Omaha all you got left is December 6th
at the Town Hall Theatre in New York
City second show 10:30
there's tickets left for the first show
but do not touch those tickets they want
over I love
those things let them burn in hell for
trying to scout from you guys you're my
family
35 hours flat I love you guys have a
great week
I want to thank Rudy again I want to
thank the [ __ ] but most
importantly I want to thank you mother
[ __ ] savages for always having my
back and live it all back all right
stay black oh [ __ ] we almost forgot here
I gotta let you know who Bob's is this
[ __ ] for starters let me talk to
you real quick
the church is sponsored by tushy you
like Joey what's tushy it's an amazing
unconventional gift for anybody in your
life everybody has an [ __ ] and
everybody deserves the gift of douchey
wiping your [ __ ] muffler with dried
toilet paper does not remove all this
[ __ ]
if you got poop when the other other
list a couple of weeks ago I threw my
shoulder
I couldn't wipe my hand with my left my
right hand had to switch to my left hand
this is not good this is where how long
so she comes in and I'll never forget
them for helping me out and someday you
guys will get hold and you can't wipe
your ass with your white pant what are
you gonna do so she's gonna be there why
because it sprays nice warm cool water
directly into your [ __ ] and it
removes the poop and all the other germs
that you got the can cause to
hemorrhoids yeast infection itchy ass
old skid marks and people not wanting to
suck your dick you ever have a girl
ready to suck your dick but she gets
away from the [ __ ] south
it's your [ __ ] it's on fire all right
but that's the days of common all over
the world but they saves you money on
toilet paper and you won't kill that
many trees you won't clog your toilet
listen till she sprays your ass with
fresh water it's not toilet water - she
connects to the water supply behind your
toilet to spray your [ __ ] nut sack
and your [ __ ] tip-top Magoo clean
with the same water you brush your teeth
with that's not inspiring but you know
wet wipes are worse than toilet paper
all right they cause anal [ __ ] little
fishes in you [ __ ] you don't want
that either in the later rounds when you
know things get rough and you got a
little pimple back there whatever listen
till she starts at $79 I'm hooking you
up it this is the gift you've been
looking for you're thinking about what I
gotta bite
I'm polish here this is the gift nice
and easy it installs in 10 minutes and
guess what that person's asked for won't
stink anymore you've done something
nicer and Leigh's had it for what three
or four years it's done every day it's
still working his [ __ ] still stinks
like water in that [ __ ] from
time to time listen I love Toshi and
I've got out of before years and I'm
gonna keep using pushy
the aim is tremendous you dry off of
that little [ __ ] hand little voodoo
towels they got look do me a favor just
go to hello Trisha calm look at all the
colors look at all the matches look at
the towel look at the stuff they got
they're a great company they got a
60-day guarantee on it but listen me and
Leo tell you with both fat bucks that
tushie still spraying water in our
[ __ ] go - hello - she calm right now
press in church and get 10% off you
ordered delivered right to your
[ __ ] house the church is also
brought to you by on it listen right now
alpha brain only company if you're not
happy with the product they give you how
the percent money-back guarantee that's
how much other believes in alpha brain
they're running a contest you order a
dirty count 60 count 90 count of on it
alpha brain and there's gonna be a
raffle ticket if you [ __ ] win in
January they're gonna fly to the honors
Center two thousand cash three days of
one-on-one training vitamins it's [ __ ]
too real it's too real to be true do me
a favor go to alikom right now look at
the selection they got make sure you get
out for brain you're a little [ __ ]
confused lately I'm the way out of check
out press in charge CH you are CH get
10% off delivered right to your house
and since you're taking care of yourself
at haunted I might as well talk to you
about athletic greens what's athletic
greens it's an awesome supplement that
gives you tremendous energy listen if
you're not starting your day off with a
blast of vitamins you're wasting your
time go back to bed but if you want to
feel tip-top Magoo let aesthetic greens
do the dirty work
no more pill bottles no more trying to
choke down a dozen Apple it's all in
there
the best part is the powder comes with
an easy-to-use travel pack
I love disguise when I'm on the road I
throw it in my bag and I know I'll be
protected you know you go out there you
smoke dope with people people shake your
hands they're filthy [ __ ] animals
with athletic greens it's like a daily
insurance policy between me and my body
I drink this then I can have a little
bit of fun and you can relax because
they're ingredients a plant-based if
you're on keto gluten-free you can take
this no chemicals no artificial flavors
no artificial preservatives no GMOs no
sugar no sweeteners no corn no lactose
no sucrose no egg no yeast no peanuts no
animal products athletic greens got what
you're looking for guys you need to take
care of yourself and that's why I
recommend these supplements to everybody
just add a little bit of cold water
shake it up you can take that banana and
shut up your mother's ass what the [ __ ]
are you waiting for right now the church
family gets a special offer all right
I'm gonna give you 20 free travel packs
valued at $79 with your first purchase
jump off let it greens calm right now
Preston Church to get your travel packs
today that's athletic green calm slash
church athletic greens they're [ __ ]
tremendous I want to thank athletic
greens or tank on it and most
importantly I want to thank Khushi but I
want to thank you guys again for being a
tremendous [ __ ] audience I'll see you
guys next week
Li take this [ __ ] meal